hello everyone I am Elena Dutra today I
want to tell you about someone who
inspires me her name is Malala why
Malala is my inspiration Malala is a
young woman who made a big difference in
the world she's famous because she's the
youngest person to ever win the Noel
prize this is a very special award given
to people who do amazing things to help
others Malala was born on July 12th
1997 in a city called mingora which is
in
Pakistan her dad zodin and her mom talk
Pai always supported her love for
learning Malala also was two younger
brothers even when she was little Mal
loved school and learning new things
school was a big part of her life
because her dad also run a school in the
city so learning was something that
whole family cared
about but when Malala was just 10 years
old something really sad happened in her
town a group called the Taliban to
control and there and and then didn't
want girls to go to
school they also banned fun things like
watching TV or
dancing this was scary for Malala and
her friends because they're all loved
learning girls like Malala has to stop
going to school and miss out of learning
just because there were girls girls even
through prove it was dangerous Malala
didn't give up on her dreams she keept
saying girl she would be able to go to
school too she was Brave and she keept
speaking out for what she believed was
right even when was
hard hard malal spes me because she show
us that anyone can make a big chance in
the
world even someone who is Young or small
she reminds me that if you believe in
something you should be keep trying no
matter what malal courage and
determinated help me see that even small
actions can have a big
impact bye-bye